[Music]
[Applause]
when audiences went to see alien
theaters back in 1979 they were
introduced to a new creature as
terrifying I stopped a war a totally
unique we wanted to make a game that we
captured that original experience we
wanted to make the aliens scary again
depending on how cautious players are
we've seen encounters in alien isolation
last well over 30 minutes in some cases
and this just can't be done with
scripted behavior as soon as the player
can predict a pattern in the alien it
stops being scary it doesn't follow any
prescribed path or set of behaviors that
are telling you to do specific things
it's just reacting to the players
presence and the choices that the player
makes the end really is hunting it is
using active senses and moment amount
decision-making to hunt me down and kill
me
if you look back at the first film is
many top body shots the alien the attack
obviously we need to expand upon that
and if you think about high moves when
he's slow give that eerie creepy feeling
back to him and when he's moving fast
but to have that agility to get to you
at any point and chase you down
the aliens are huge and the environments
are all down to scale with the film sets
and we need to move in through them at
full speed we don't want you to see the
scree animations what we want is smooth
continuous movement we wanted to look
alive this is an enemy that you need to
avoid all costs an alien that is
stalking you that's intelligent
unpredictable extremely dangerous even
if you find a gun your first thought is
going to be if I fire this will the
alien hear it alien isolation is about
encounters that are meaningful and
terrifying so that even when the alien
is not scream they'd be terrified by the
thought that will be around the next
corner this is a game where you'll never
feel safe
you